Pharrell Williams is bringing things
full-circle calling on his own personal
mentor Sean Diddy Combs aka Puff Daddy
to join the upcoming season of The Voice
only et was on the set tell me why you
wanted to call up Sean to help you out
this season he was the one who looked at
me and said you know you got a you got
to do more than be behind the keyboards
you have to get in front of the keyboard
as well and I didn't at the time I was
like what I had already gotten rid of
the dreams of being a performer I was I
was past that you know but he was the
one that identified so much more in me
like I mean I'm on a show like this you
know among many other things and had I
just stayed in my comfort zone I
wouldn't have known that there's so much
more that I could do in the world and so
you know why not go to the guy that did
that for me and bring that to the show
actually thank you to you Sean because I
think the world is a better place for
having for I'll perform don't you for
you about being here teaming up with FRA
Lagaan and getting to mentor these kids
I mean for me um not sense making the
band about you know been able to really
work you know on this scale with artists
like new brand new artists most artists
I work with the sign to my label use me
an unsigned acts that we don't know you
know where they don't go to they could
be the next you know Katy Perry we don't
know when it's the this endless on how
big they could be so getting a chance to
you know even be a part of their lives
to start
that is a lesson